herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen faz
anspruch podcast spezial dem podcast der
faz zu politik recht und justiz wir
senden heute eine sonderfolge denn in
europa herrscht krieg in den straßen
einer europäischen hauptstadt wird
gekämpft was heißt das für unser recht
was heißt das für die ordnung in der wir
leben mein name ist reinhard müller ich
bin verantwortliche redakteur der faz
für zeitgeschehen staat und recht und
eben faz einspruch und bei mir ist
stephan klenner stefan keller ist
redakteur von anspruch und wir haben uns
kurzfristig entschlossen aufgrund der
besonderen lage diese spezial folge zu
machen natürlich hat uns das thema
ukraine schon länger in der redaktion
beschäftigt schon die ganzen letzten
wochen aber nach den ereignissen am
donnerstagmorgen bei uns dann klar dass
wir das thema rechtlich einordnen müssen
und haben dann eben sehr sehr
kurzfristig jetzt diese sonderfolge
geplant und wir sind froh dass es uns
trotzdem gelungen ist in dieser kurzen
zeit zwei hochkarätige gesprächspartner
zu gewinnen herr müller sie interviewen
gleich angelika nußberger angelika
nußberger ist professorin für
völkerrecht und rechts vergleichende
verfassungslehre wenn man so will ist
auch ost rechnerin und slawistin kennt
also das worüber wir sprechen wollen
sehr genau nicht nur von der rechtlichen
warte aus gesehen und sie war vize
präsidentin am europäischen gerichtshof
für menschenrechte der auch eine lange
geschichte mit russland hat unser
zweiter gesprächspartner ist christoph
safferling christoph safferling ist
professor für strafrecht
strafprozessrecht
internationales strafrecht und
völkerrecht an der universität erlangen
nürnberg
ich werde ihn fragen ob und wie mögliche
völker rechtsverstöße strafrechtlich
geahndet werden können und zwar nicht
nur auf internationaler ebene sondern
auch hier bei uns in deutschland und
zwischen diesen beiden gesprächen werfen
wir einen blick auf beiträge die wir in
der vz und zwar am anspruch magazin zur
lage hatten auch da gab es spannende
debatten ja wir werden also dieses ganze
thema ukraine und die aktuelle situation
aus ganz unterschiedlichen perspektiven
beleuchten und wir beginnen jetzt mit
ihrem interview mit frau nußberger
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen frau professor lutz
berger sie lehrt
verfassungsrecht und rechtsvergleichung
und ist auch slawistin und war vize
präsidentin des europäischen gerichtshof
für menschenrechte herzlich willkommen
fuchsberger sie hatten einen spannenden
aktuellen beitrag auf faz ein spruch
geschrieben wo sie schlossen mit den
worten angesichts des krieges in der
ukraine das recht muss dem unrecht nicht
weichen auch wenn ein staat das unrecht
zur staatsraison erklärt aber im moment
erleben wir doch praktisch dass das
recht dem unrecht weicht klingt das
nicht ein bisschen naiv wenn man sagt
das recht muss nicht weichen aber alle
menschen erleben zurzeit
massive
rechtsverletzungen brüche des
völkerrechts
die frage wie man da auf ihn weiter
macht und inwieweit man weiter arbeitet
mit der für europa aufgebauten friedens
architektur also sprich europarat
insbesondere indem er russland
einbezogen ist und meine aussage war
dahingehend dass natürlich jetzt für
alle sichtbar ist das hatte ich auch
geschrieben dass die machtpolitik jetzt
im vordergrund steht und die
europäischen hoffnungen 4 in einer
sackgasse erstmal zu sein scheinen aber
es sei jedoch wichtig gleich weiter zu
denken dass man diese strukturen weil
sie jetzt eben im moment gescheitert
sind nicht aufgeben darf und wie
weiterführen auf der anderen seite gibt
es eine lange geschichte der gewalt der
aktion der verletzung der territorialen
integrität von nachbarstaaten russlands
durch russland und sie selbst haben eine
lange erfahrung von verfahren gegen
russland hat sie das überrascht dieser
ausbruch der gewalt aufgrund ihres
bisherigen wissens
leider kann ich mich sagen dass er mich
wirklich überrascht hätte ich fand es
war von langer hand jetzt vorbereitet
dass eben die zivilgesellschaft und die
freie betätigung der meinungsfreiheit
immer weiter unterbunden wurde und es
immer mehr sich zugespitzt hat auch auf
ein freund feind denken auch in der
propaganda und die
die elemente die eigentlich dazu geführt
hätten sich hier noch ein gebunden zu
fühlen in dieses in diese friedens
architektur immer weiter zurückgedrängt
worden sind von daher wäre das wort
überrascht nicht wirklich richtig sie
sprachen es an wir hatten ja und eine
vielzahl von militärisch ausgefochtenen
konflikten in denen jeweils auch das
völkerrecht strapaziert worden ist oder
letztlich eingesetzt worden ist in einer
wende das völkerrecht nicht verstanden
werden kann und von daher hatte sich
angedeutet dass weitere eskalation geben
könnte von der heftigkeit und von der
von der unverfrorenheit wie sie jetzt
tatsächlich
durchgeführt worden ist in diesen tagen
davon waren war ich jedenfalls
überrascht und sicherlich viele andere
auch gibt es denn etwas
charakteristisches der
menschenrechtsverletzungen in russland
durch das putin regime wenn man auch auf
diese historie vor dem europäischen
gerichtshof für menschenrechte blickt er
hatte ja auch versucht der präsident
dafür persönlich mal zu intervenieren
erkennt solche gerichtsbarkeit im grunde
nicht an gibt es ein besonderes
spezifikum der art wie menschenrechte in
russland unterdrückt werden es sind sehr
viele menschenrechtsverletzungen in
allem in letzter zeit gewesen in denen
der gerichtshof dann auch at&t 18 heran
gezogen hat artikel 8 und ist also
machtmissbrauch das also rechte nicht
nur begrenzt werden und man dann über
die verhältnismäßigkeit der begrenzung
nachdenken kann sondern dass die rechts
begrenzung von vornherein eigentlich als
mit anderen zwecken als services
verfolgt hat und diese artikel 18
rechtsprechung die galt immer so als die
ultima sie warnen davor dass eine
entwicklung in die falsche richtung geht
und da hatten wir eben nicht nur
weißrussland muss ich auch sagen aber
eben auch verstärkt mit russland oder
zweite charakteristische im umgang
russlands auch mit einer menschenrechts
rechtsprechung war dass die in der
verfassung einen etat verankert haben um
bestimmte entscheidungen die aus ihrer
sicht nicht mit der verfassung in der
russischen verfassung vereinbar
vereinbar wären nicht anzuerkennen und
dieser filter der wurde eingesetzt eben
bei dem motto kosky verfahren im
wirtschaftlichen bereich und der war
aber auch schon eine klare warnung wir
machen mit komma aber also da ist es in
anderen staaten sind auch kritisch
gewesen aber nicht er hatte kein staat
einen derartigen nichtanerkennung
mechanismus gegenüber urteilen in der
auf der ebene der verfassung verankert
also ein vorbehalt sozusagen das war ja
die individual- rechtliche ebene jetzt
sind wir sozusagen auf der
zwischenstaatlichen gibt es da auch sie
jetzt angesprochen als ost richterin und
slawistin aber auch als vergleichende
verfassungsexperten gibt es ein
besonderes ost recht auch im völkerrecht
eine tradition das
selbstbestimmungsrecht anders zu sehen
etwa als es der westen tat
in der wissenschaft wird diese position
zunehmend deutlich vertreten da gibt es
einen ethnischen völkerrechtlern audimax
und auch eine doktorin informiert hat
kürzlich darüber geschrieben
dass eben aus russischer sicht hier mit
begriffen wie gerade selbstbestimmung
anders umgegangen wird und zwar insofern
problematisch als eben dieser
grundkonflikt fall das kosovo einerseits
genommen wird um zu sagen da ist völlig
gebrochen worden aber dann genau dieser
fall genommen wird um was ja letztlich
an aktionen oder abspaltungen von
gebieten von anderen staaten wiederum zu
recht
und da hat man in der letzten zeit
wirklich einen zynischen umgang mit
völkerrechtlichen argumentation formen
beobachten können was er jetzt auch in
dieser putin rede vom montag wieder
deutlich war als er auf genozid verwies
ohne irgendeine sachliche grundlage
dafür zu haben und damit natürlich an
gespielt hat auf die damalige begründung
für den nato-einsatz in libyen
haben sie das damals für richtig und
plausibel gehalten die humanitäre
intervention zugunsten der kosovo
albaner ich war damals ehrlich gesagt
auch sehr kritisch dieser humanitären
intervention gegenüber weil sie eben
hier mit diesem sehr schwer definieren
beim begriff der das genozid gearbeitet
hat und damit natürlich ein begründung
store aufgemacht hat für das was dann ja
auch eins nach dem anderen gekommen ist
von georgien mit südosseten mit
abchasien mit transnistrien da waren ja
dann immer wieder diese argumente
verwendet worden und da ist eben ein
großer unsicherheitsfaktor
in die völkerrechtliche argumentation
hineingekommen der hat dazu geführt dass
eben diese diese doch sehr strikte regel
das gewaltverbot immer wieder und immer
neu unterlaufen werden konnte deshalb
denke ich mich persönlich fragen habe
ich damals mit großer sorge beobachtet
und wenn man diese argumentation
aufgreift gibt es denn nach ihrer
kenntnis anhaltspunkte für zumindest
eine diskriminierung von russen oder von
solchen die sich als russen fühlen in
diesen gebieten der ost ukraine die
zumindest ein genaues hinschauen
erforderten ein genaues hinschauen war
natürlich immer erforderlich meine
ukraine war ja früher eigentlich
dominant zweisprachig und auch
unproblematisch zweisprachig also ich
habe mit ukrainischen kollegen erlebt
dass sie am telefon mitten im gespräch
von einer in die andere sprache geweckt
haben es war etwas sehr sehr
selbstverständlich ist und man hat auf
dieser sprach problematik mehr an
problemen gemacht als ursprünglich
eigentlich drin war es stimmt natürlich
dass ihm im westen mehr das ukrainische
gesprochen wurde im osten mehr dass
russische und es stimmt auch dass die
ukraine das ukrainische vor allem auch
in der letzten zeit sehr stark gestärkt
hat aber das ist so viele meilen
entfernt von einem begriff wie die in
putin verwendet hat mit genozid es war
es war ein versuch der ukraine sicher
selbst zu finden den man kritisieren
konnte wohl auch kritisieren musste den
auch die genetik kommission zum beispiel
zum teil kritisiert hat aber das waren
diskutierbar
entwicklung wo man sagen kann hinein ihr
müsst ihr müsst ihr die
minderheitensprachen oder die die
sprache der russischen minderheit
besser mit
einfügen in euer ganzes das ist
sicherlich so aber das war in keinster
weise irgendwie eine art des
ausschlusses der russischsprachigen
bevölkerung die ja
dem sid ähnlichen zuständen geführt
hätte schwingt jetzt in dieser
russischen aggression auch noch etwas
von der breschnew doktrin oder von einer
doktrin mit die eine art dominanz einen
natürlichen luminanz ein großes
russisches gewalt streben auch rechtlich
rechtfertigen will
ja rechtlich und restore ist hier auch
sehr stark also es ist ja die
argumentation sehr stark auch auf
geschichte aufgebaut und
auffälligkeiten der geschichte die
rückgängig gemacht werden sollten obwohl
man ja die anerkennung der grenzen als
grundlage sieht und die breschnew
doktrin schwingt mit also die der
grundgedanke hier ein historisches
kontinuum erhalten zu wollen das 1990
aus widrigen umständen
auseinandergebrochen ist und jetzt
dieses conti nun wieder zusammenzufügen
und wieder letztlich abzusichern mit
einer mit einem bollwerk gegen den
besten mit quasi großbuchstaben
geschrieben das ist das ist durchaus in
der argumentation von russischer seite
zu erkennen nun kann man ja
argumentieren dass historischer
ethnische argumente auch sonst verwendet
werden der unterschied ist jetzt
natürlich diese massive gewalt überhaupt
die überschreitung von grenzen die
verletzung und territorialer integrität
eines anerkannten nachbarlandes gibt es
da ein besonderes verhältnis auch einen
niedrigschwelligen zugang zu gewalt ja
also der einsatz von gewalt ich jetzt
einfach als mittel auch vorbereitet
worden ist gedacht worden das haben wir
auch in den anderen konflikten ja
gesehen dass schnell mit gewalt reagiert
worden ist aber letztlich doch noch mehr
in dosierter form als es sich jetzt ja
hier angebahnt hat und ja auch
vorbereitet also vor der ganzen welt
öffentlichkeit ausgebreitet wurde ja
diese gewalt kulisse aufgebaut die ja
auch schon völkerrechtswidrig war mit
seiner drohung in verhandlungen zu gehen
da war sicherlich eine eine große
bereitschaft den worten unmittelbar
taten folgen zu lassen die man bisher so
weder als du gehst dennoch auch dann in
der umsetzung zur aktion hätte erkennen
können also das ist ein vollkommen neuer
stil im umgang miteinander den mann
gedacht hatte hinter sich gelassen zu
haben und das ist glaube ich jetzt auch
der große schock der weltgemeinschaft
dass da jemand einfach wirklich alle
tabus bricht und peter bus auch nicht
mal als tabus empfindet die rechte und
wie bewahrt man dann seine werte also
man kann sie natürlich selbst
weiterleben aber gerade wenn man selbst
ein anderes verhältnis zu gewalt hat
oder die gewalt auch fürchtet auch aus
guten gründen wie kann man dann gegen
einer klasse bestehen und wie kann man
die werteordnung halten hoch halten
unterdrückte zivilgesellschaft gibt ja
auch in weißrussland ganz stark dass die
menschen da anders denken bloß die kommt
nicht kann nicht immer meinen so zum
ausdruck kommen aber da geht jedenfalls
anknüpfungspunkte aber ich gebe ihnen
insofern recht man kann nicht einfach
sagen wir reden weiter und haben keine
antwort darauf dass die anderen nicht
reden da wird eben sehr viel jetzt neu
gedacht werden müssen aus meiner sicht
war der europarat eben immer noch 100
ist an dem alle saßen und ich fand es
immer noch großartig dass man eben mit
den russen hier auf gleicher ebene in
einer gemeinschaft eingebunden sprechen
konnte das wird kaum mehr funktionieren
jetzt in der zukunft und wie man das er
selbst welche neuen formate man findet
das wird die zukunft zeigen aber man
darf nicht jetzt
quasi die ordnung die man nun über 70
jahre aufgebaut hat
als für bankrott erklären man muss man
muss man sie retten man muss aber
versuchen wie man sie so retten kann
dass sie einen einen solchen test wie
sie ihn jetzt ausgesetzt war auch
bestehen könnte wobei ich gebe ihnen
recht wenn jemand wirklich die regeln
die er erst unterschreibt überhaupt
nicht einhält dann ist man eben mit
rechtlichen mitteln auch auch am ende
das latein erstmal und wie kann man die
zivilgesellschaft die demokratischen
kräfte von denen sich natürlich putin
fürchtet die freiheit stärken und
zugleich spürbare signal und spürbare
sanktionen verhängen das ist ja auch
eine herausfordernde könnte boykottieren
wie das auch mit sport veranstaltet und
geschieht oder angekündigt ist man
könnte also sagen wir wollen kanäle
offen halten ja bei muskel versuchen oft
eigentlich glaube dass auch
sprechweise sehr wichtig ist also ganzer
stolz hat ja auch gesagt seit putins
krieg und hat also die trennungen hier
gemacht ich glaube dass viele russische
mit bürgerinnen und bürger jetzt in der
tat genauso fassungslos sind und dass
man zumindest erstmal schon von rhetorik
die mit auffangen muss dass man das
sieht das was da nicht alle wirklich
dahinter stehen das ist ein erster
schritt und es ist eben eine hoffnung
dass irgendwann aus dieser
zivilgesellschaft dann doch einen
widerstand complus ehrlich gesagt so wie
die entwicklung in den letzten jahren
war und sie schnell jetzt auch die
demonstration die wenigen die es gab
dann sofort im keim erstickt worden sind
muss man auch hier nicht naiv sein dass
es ein einfaches mittel wäre die credit
gesellschaft hier zu aktivieren können
sie putin und vielleicht auch jeder
verstehen die sich eingekreist fühlen
von der wertegemeinschaft nato die
niemand heran gerückt ist
ja also er hat sich ja offensichtlich da
jetzt ein weltbild der zunehmenden
einkreisung aufgebaut aus dem er dann
glaubte nur noch als sich mit gewalt
befreien zu können
was heißt verstehen hier in dem
zusammenhang also man kann es nicht
verstehen wie man aufgrund dessen eben
grenzen nicht mehr anerkennen kann weil
selbst die einkreisung in
anführungszeichen hat ja keine grenzen
verletzt sondern das war ja ein
einbinden anderer staaten in andere
gemeinschaften also das wort verstehen
will ich da nicht nicht verwenden weil
ich nicht verstehen können will aber die
die denkweise die eben aus dem was sie
ja vor den ansprachen mit der breschnew
doktrin die aus dieser welt stammt von
einem russisch dominierten kontinuum das
abgefedert ist an den an den grenzen
wenn man aus dieser weltsicht heraus
denkt und dann sieht dass die sich
verschoben hat und dass die anderen
staaten außenrum eben diese welt sich
nicht teilen dann kann man sich
vorstellen dass sich jemand daran
steigert und meint wenn er nur die macht
hat dann wird er dann wird er das ändern
und das war ja immer schon bekannt für
putin der nato bombardement auf belgrad
der absolute wendepunkt dem west
gegenüber war und dass er damals eben
das gefühl hatte dass russland quasi
ohnmächtig ist hier zu reagieren und das
ist wenn sie jetzt nachdem verstehen
fragen ist es quasi der lackierprozess
von damals bis heute ist es dann die
antwort so sagen jetzt bin ich so
mächtig jetzt kann ich die antwort geben
die ich auch tatsächlich eben bin
stichwort ohnmacht der westen gibt sich
jetzt eine blöße mehr aus sagt wir haben
es lange falsch gesehen wie es stehen
blank da wie ein general sagt wir haben
ihn unterschätzt offensichtlich obwohl
die zeichen immer lesbar waren wie muss
man jetzt selbst ein eigenes verhältnis
auch zum selbstverteidigungsrecht wenn
wir über unsere ordnung sprechen neu
definieren es hat sich ja gezeigt dass
das
papierne recht oder das auch
institutionen wie der europarat nicht zu
einer anhebung dieses aggressions
denkens geführt haben und das womöglich
nur eine andere botschaft verstanden
wird die jetzt nicht außerhalb des
völkerrechts liegt sondern geradezu eine
belebung eine ausformulierung der
selbstbestimmungsrechte
selbstverteidigungsrecht auch bedeuten
würden muss man da jetzt auch neu
nachdenken ja ich da ich denke dass es
hier ein umdenken geben muss geben wird
wir hatten ja in der letzten zeit viel
diskutiert was held in europa zusammen
und dann war immer so das allgemeine
narrativ die friedensidee das ist der
jugend ist uns so selbstverständlich
geworden
damit können wir gar keine kids mehr
schaffen für diese europäischen
institutionen das wird man von dem
letzten montag vom letzten dienstag an
anders sehen man wird wieder neu
verstehen was wirklich bewirkt hat 70
jahre am runden tisch zu sitzen und eben
miteinander zu sprechen auch uneinig zu
sein aber eben miteinander zu sprechen
und man wird diese diese friedensidee
wieder ganz anders in den vordergrund
stehen aber stellen aber dann auch im
zusammenhang damit
selbstverteidigung dass man den frieden
eben im zweifel auch durchsetzen können
wenn jemand diese werte ganz
grundsätzlich nicht teilt also es ist
auch ein kampf ums recht
es bleibt ein kampf darum das recht zu
erhalten dass wir jetzt wirklich als
errungenschaft empfunden haben und dass
auch 70 jahre schrieben weitgehenden
trieben es war ja kein vollkommen baff
linien europa aber doch weitgehend
frieden gesichert hat da müssen wir
schauen wie wir das erhalten können und
trotz dieses dieses einbruchs in der
welt ganz herzlich dankt frau professor
losberger für dieses gespräch
wir kommen nun zu einem überblick über
beiträge die wir insbesondere im
einspruch magazin zur lage in der
ukraine zum krieg dort hatten herr
klenner wie haben wir das thema dort
behandelt ja das war schon die letzten
wochen thema und zwei autorin von
gastbeiträgen im einspruch magazin sind
den hörern des podcasts auch schon
bekannt am 27 januar hat schon frau
professor anne peters sich damit
beschäftigt dass die damalige lage auch
schon völker rechtsverstöße bewirkt hat
also dass russland auch schon damals
gegen das völkerrecht verstoßen hat
dadurch dass sie ebenso eine
bedrohungssituation an der grenze zur
ukraine aufgebaut haben darüber hat
corinna budras hier im podcast schon mit
frau peters am 16 februar gesprochen ja
und auch die zweite gast autorin ist
schon gut bekannt eben durch ihr
interview herr müller angelika nußberger
hat direkt am donnerstag an dem tag als
dann die angriffe losgehen
einen beitrag bei uns geschrieben ob wir
jetzt eigentlich noch an die werte
europas glauben können aber das waren
natürlich nicht die einzigen beiträge
sondern wir hatten diese woche auch zwei
spannende beiträge aus der faz dann auch
auf einspruch in beiden artikeln ging es
um das völkerrecht herr müller was gab
es da zu lesen zum einen hat christian
walther lehrstuhlinhaber in münchen auf
das selbstbestimmungsrecht bezug
genommen und hat von einer perversion
dieses selbstbestimmungsrechts durch
putin gesprochen in dem er auch mal die
bezüge herstellen und sagte ja es gibt
ein problem wenn eine volksgruppe ein
volk eine teilrepublik womöglich
unterdrückt wird gar vom völkermord
bedroht ist stichwort kosovo aber das
hier putin einfach ohne jede belege
tatsachen geschaffen hat und
einmarschiert ist bevor man überhaupt
irgendwas prüfen konnte und da sprache
eben von einer perversion des
selbstbestimmungsrechts und erinnerte
auch daran völlig zu recht dass
natürlich auch die ukraine also die
starts nation ukraine deren existenz
putin bestreitet ein recht auf
selbstbestimmung haben der zweite
artikel war etwas theoretisch aber auch
trotzdem hoch spannend und in die zeit
passen nämlich von ulrich fastenrath der
einen buchs berühmten finnischen
völkerrechtlers kosky niemi zum anlass
genommen hat mal über die deutsche
dogmatik und das deutsche verständnis
von recht nachzudenken die ziemlich
einzigartig sind und so ein bisschen
suggerieren es gibt immer eine auslegung
die auch richtig ist und das ist eben
nicht so wie ein blick über unsere
grenzen zeigt recht ist eben auch
veränderlich und kein ruhendes
entscheidungs programm wie er schreibt
sondern es gibt verschiedene
vorstellungen die da einfließen recht
kann eben auch wie jetzt auch putin
gezeigt hat instrumentalisiert werden
und das müssen wir uns auch klar machen
und um so wichtiger ist eben dann auch
wie wir uns jetzt zur krise in der
ukraine verhalten ja und dieser blick
über die grenzen ist natürlich auch ganz
wichtig um die rechts diskussion zu der
aktuellen lage in der ukraine zu
verstehen einen weiteren blick nicht
über die grenzen sondern quasi einen
blick in die rechtsgeschichte haben sie
dann in der freitagsausgabe der faz
geworfen und sich mit karl schmidt
beschäftigt was hat karl schmidt mit der
aktuellen lage in der ukraine zu tun das
ist natürlich immer zweifelhaft den
krohn juristen hitlers gleichsam noch
mal wieder aus dem graben zu holen aber
es gab schon diskussion anfang der 30er
jahre über großräume und intervention
verbote zwischen den sphären der
großmächte hintergrund war die monroe
doktrin des gleichnamigen amerikanischen
präsidenten der eben gesagt hat ihr
europäischen mächte mischt euch bitte
bei uns nicht einen wir uns nicht bei
euch und jeder kann in seinem hinterhof
zugespitzt gesagt machen was er will
und karl schmidt hat sich ausdrücklich
unter bezug darauf gegen eine
universalistische theorie gesagte
genannt und gegen minderheitenschutz
sondern eben gesagt also das würde dazu
führen dass man überall auf der welt
intervenieren könne und wenn man das so
weiter denkt ist es schon ganz
interessant dass von dieser alten
ordnung noch ein bisschen überlebt hat
weil ja auch die großmächte russland
china vereinigte staaten natürlich immer
auch besonderes augenmerk auf ihre
unmittelbaren nachbarn gelegt haben und
auch privilegiert sind denn sie sind
alle mitglieder im sicherheitsrat und
zwar ständige mitglieder mit vetorecht
also auch unter der un-charta sind nicht
alle staaten gleich
freitag hatten wir dann noch einen
weiteren beitrag von christian richter
von der führungsakademie der bundeswehr
zur aktuellen lage den beitrag kann ich
vor allem auch unseren hörern empfehlen
die sich vielleicht auf eine mündliche
prüfung im staatsexamen vorbereiten weil
er da noch mal so ganz
schulmäßig durch prüft gegen welche
normen des völkerrechts wird eigentlich
gerade durch russland verstoßen und er
geht auch auf mögliche
rechtfertigungsgründe ein schaut die
sich also auch ganz genau an gibt es da
eine möglichkeit diesen angriff in
irgendeiner weise zu rechtfertigen das
verneint er aber gerade auch im
prüfungsgespräch ist so was sicherlich
sehr sehr gut zu wissen und das will ich
auch zum anlass nehmen noch einmal zu
erklären wie man eigentlich diese
beiträge des faz einspruch magazins
lesen kann da gibt es zwei möglichkeiten
einmal übers netz einfach fasnet
schrägstrich einspruch oder natürlich
auch über die faz einspruch ab das ganze
ist mit einem abo verbunden was für
unter 35 jährige also dem alter wo
prüfungskandidaten in der regel noch
anzusiedeln sind vier euro 95 im monat
umfasst wenn man etwas älter ist muss
man dann 14 euro 90 im monat bezahlen
und das ganze kann auch vier wochen
gratis getestet werden und wir freuen
uns natürlich wenn es auch zusätzliche
abos gibt weil mit den abos vom faz
einspruch magazin unterstützen sie
natürlich auch immer diesen podcast so
ist es vielen dank herr keller und wir
hoffen auf weitere abonnenten und freuen
uns jetzt auf das interview mit
christoph safferling
[Musik]
bei mir im faz einspruch podcast ist
jetzt christoph safferling professor für
strafrecht strafprozessrecht
internationales strafrecht und
völkerrecht an der universität
erlangen-nürnberg guten tag herr
safferling hallo ihr kleiner herr
safferling wir wollen uns heute ein
bisschen mit der strafrechtlichen
bewertung der aktuellen lage in der
ukraine beschäftigen und zunächst würde
ich mir gerne mit ihnen das römische
statut des internationalen
strafgerichtshofs
angucken da muss man natürlich zwei
dinge unterscheiden zum einen ist ja die
frage ob ein konkreter konflikt
überhaupt vor dem internationalen
strafgerichtshof
verhandelt werden könnte das will ich
jetzt erst mal außen vor lassen sondern
mich erstmal mit den materiellen
straftatbeständen beschäftigen welche
tatbestände des statuts könnten denn im
aktuellen konflikt in der ukraine eine
rolle spielen also ich würde das pferd
an der stelle vielleicht mal ein
bisschen von hinten aufzäumen die
tatbestände die auch schon ursprünglich
also seit 1998 im römischen statut sich
wiederfinden es sind einmal das
verbrechen gegen die menschlichkeit die
kriegsverbrechen und der völkermord und
hier kommen letztlich auch also
jedenfalls verbrechen die menschlichkeit
und kriegsverbrechen in betracht das
hängt natürlich dann von den einzelnen
situationen ab inwiefern hier im zuge
der kriegerischen auseinandersetzungen
diese tatbestände erfüllt sind aber das
wäre jedenfalls durchaus denkbar
realistisch und erfahrungsgemäß ja auch
der fall dass man hier wegen verbrechen
gegen die menschlichkeit und
kriegsverbrechen
dann vorgehen könnte das möglicherweise
an der stelle bei interessantere
verbrechen ist das verbrechen der
aggression und das ist ein etwas später
erst ins römische statut hineingekommen
tatbestand etwas später deshalb weil man
sich eben auf der römischen konferenz
1998 bei der erstellung des statuts auf
eine formulierung dieses aggressions
tatbestandes nicht verständigen konnte
das liegt an verschiedenen ringen vor
allem liegt es daran dass dieser
tatbestand eben einen ganz starken
völkerrechts bezug hat und letztlich gar
nicht so sehr dass individuen als
verbrecher in den vordergrund stellt
sondern ein staat praktisch anklagt das
verhalten des staates als aggressiven
akt dann zum gegenstand hat und da sieht
die staaten eben immer vorsichtig sich
selbst als aggressor dann bezeichnen
lassen zu müssen dieser tatbestand kamen
deswegen erst im jahr 2011 ins römische
statut nach einer großen
nachfolgekonferenz in kampala wo man
sich dann auf eine formulierung
verständigt hat ja genau ich würde auch
direkt mir mal die formulierung so ein
bisschen angucken also da geht es ja
darum dass auch schon die planung und
die vorbereitung einer angriffs handlung
sanktioniert werden kann allerdings auch
erst ab einer gewissen schwere und einem
gewissen umfang ja wie muss man das
jetzt hier einschätzen ist es so dass
dieser tatbestand quasi dann seit
donnerstagmorgen verwirklicht wurde oder
möglicherweise schon vorher aufgrund der
der planung oder was was muss dafür
erfüllt seien ja das ist natürlich eine
ganz ganz schwierige frage und dies auch
deswegen schwierig und er ist zu
schwierig zu beurteilen weil es keine
präzedenzfälle gibt den einen
präzedenzfall den mann vor einem
strafgericht auch schon einmal zur
verurteilung hat kommen lassen das war
eben im nürnberger
hauptkriegsverbrecherprozess
die aggression deutschlands gegenüber
polen und und anderen anderen staaten
und da war der tatbestand noch etwas
anders formuliert und damals waren die
verhältnisse natürlich irgendwie auch
besonders klar
jetzt verlangt der tatbestand eine
manifeste verletzung der un charta
und das ist oftmals schon gar nicht so
einfach das letztlich nachzuweisen vor
allem weil es eben eine manifeste also
eine offenkundige verletzung sein muss
sobald also hier zweifel bestehen ob
nicht vielleicht doch ein rechtfertigung
tatbestand in betracht kommt kann man
schon wieder ins diskutieren kommen die
rechtfertigung tatbestände oder umstände
die jetzt hier der russische präsident
angeführt hat die kommen glaube ich hier
nicht durch also da sehe ich keinen
ansatz in der in der un-charta dass man
sagen könnte hier russland hätte sich
möglicherweise selbst verteidigen müssen
oder wollte einen völkermord verhindern
das sind ja im grunde lächerliche
vorwürfe also der tatbestand wäre als
solcher erfüllt und auch schon die
vorbereitung erfüllt ist und wie weit
das sozusagen im vorfeld hineinreicht
das ist ganz ganz schwer zu beurteilen
jetzt wo die aggression stattgefunden
hat und putin ja auch selber gesagt hat
er hätte diesen einmarsch befohlen ist
der tatbestand erfüllt müssen wir uns
letztlich darüber keine gedanken mehr
machen wie weit im vorfeld der schon zur
anwendung gelangen kommen könnte da
haben wir das geklärt also dann wissen
wir quasi dass das verbrechen der
aggression
materiell erfüllt ist sie haben vorhin
aber auch noch zwei andere tatbestände
angesprochen und zwar verbrechen gegen
die menschlichkeit und kriegsverbrechen
können sie da unseren hörern noch mal
erklären was das zum beispiel ist und wo
auch die unterschiede dieser beiden
tatbestände liegen ja also die
kriegsverbrechen beziehen sich auf
regelungen die im rahmen des humanitären
völkerrechts immer dann gelten wenn es
einen bewaffneten konflikt gibt das hat
jetzt nichts damit zu tun ob
irgendjemand einen aggressor ist oder
eine armee sich verteidigt sondern es
gilt einfach immer wenn waffen sprechen
dann müssen sich beide parteien
unabhängig von der kriegsschuld wenn ich
das mal so nennen darf dann geht das
unabhängig davon so ein gewisser maß
gewisses maß an fairness gegenüber den
ja- und respekt gegenüber den soldaten
sozusagen der anderen partei das bezieht
und auch kriegsgefangene auf den schutz
von verletzten und verwundeten und zum
anderen eben auch auf den schutz der
zivilbevölkerung
also eine große moment was hier diesen
kriegsvölkerrecht bei den
kriegsverbrechen eben zum durchbruch
kommen soll ist die unterscheidung
zwischen militärischen und zivilen
objekten und zivile objekte anzugreifen
ist man per se verboten wäre das macht
absichtlich ein ziviles objekt an greift
also auch beispielsweise ein krankenhaus
eine schule oder eben eine wohngegend
der macht sich strafbar so das ist
dieses konzept der kriegsverbrechen und
daneben gibt es eben verbrechen gegen
die menschlichkeit die sind jetzt nicht
abhängig von einem bewaffneten konflikt
aber jetzt in unserem fall der ukraine
hätten wir den jahr aber auch im fluge
öffneten konflikt sind die anwendbar und
da geht es darum dass kriminalisiert ist
die systematische oder massenhafte
verletzung von menschenrechten wenn ich
vielleicht mal so kurz zusammenfassen
darf das ist also auch ganz klar jetzt
ein eine schutz norm für die
zivilbevölkerung also die die keine
möglichkeiten haben sich zu verteidigen
die der gewalt eines staates oder eine
armee in diesem fall hilflos
ausgeliefert sind die sind hier dann
entsprechend besonders besonders
geschützt und da gibt es eine reihe von
einzeltaten das fängt an bei tötungen
über folterungen misshandlungen
gefangennahme etc das sind dinge die
wenn sie eben im systematischen
massenhaft auftreten dann als verbrechen
gegen die menschlichkeit bestraft werden
wenn man jetzt den bisherigen
kriegsverlauf sich anguckt dann muss man
ja feststellen dass zum beispiel auch
schon zivile gebäude und auch
wohngebäude schon getroffen wurden ob
das jetzt schon kriegsverbrechen sind
das hängt also davon ab ob das quasi
absichtlich geschehen ist oder ob das
quasi versehentlich geschehen ist als
eigentlich militärische objekte
getroffen werden sollten habe ich sie
richtig verstanden real-trainer so in
etwa kann man das kann man das sagen ja
also es muss auf jeden fall erstmal
grundsätzlich unterschieden werden also
wenn jetzt eher einfach raketen
abgefeuert werden ohne dass man darauf
achtet wo die landen dann ist das schon
ein unterschied loser angriff und das
ist schon verboten und ansonsten wie
gesagt darf man nur platziert
militärische objekte an angreifen das
hat allerdings auch noch eine grenze und
zwar muss man auf ein angriff eines
militärischen objektes auch dann
unterlassen wenn die sogenannten
kollateralschäden zu hoch sind also wenn
die schäden unter die zivilbevölkerung
zu hoch sind auch wenn eigentlich ein
militärisches objekt angezählt ist das
klingt natürlich jetzt ganz gut ist
allerdings noch nie wirklich zur
anwendung gekommen weil man als staat
immer behaupten kann der militärische
vorteil so überragend dass die zivilen
opfer auch wenn das viele sind doch
irgendwie noch im verhältnis stehen das
ist natürlich eine sarkastische
abgrenzung aber so ist das recht an
dieser stelle verstehe ja ich würde
gerne noch auf einen möglichen
rechtfertigungsgrund eingehen sie hat ja
eben schon gesagt das was russland da
behauptet dass eben das ganze gemacht
werde um einen völkermord in den
separatisten gebieten zu verhindern das
sei im grunde lächerlich das ist auch
das was wir aus der nachrichtenlage
kennen es gibt aber noch einen anderen
argumentation strang von russland und
zwar vergleicht russland häufig die
situation in der ost ukraine mit der
situation im kosovo 1999
würden sie sagen auch das ist lächerlich
oder gibt es da tatsächlich parallelen
der nato-einsatz 1999 im kosovo war ja
auch kein ruhmesblatt des völkerrechts
aber die rechtfertigung die damals eben
dann letztlich auch überzeugt hat war
die humanitäre situation die gefährdung
der zivilisten zivilisten in serbien
und daraufhin wurde neben hier diese
nato-bombardements dann letztlich
völkerrechtlich als gerechtfertigt
angesehen man nennt das dann humanitäre
intervention und diese humanitäre
intervention ist
völkerrechtlich während dünnes eis aber
sie ist so zähneknirschend irgendwie
akzeptiert man muss aber natürlich dann
genau gucken wie dramatisch ist die
situation tatsächlich und kann sie
wirklich nur durch militärische mittel
dann entsprechend beendet beendet werden
also da gibt es auf jeden fall ganz klar
eine starke verhältnismäßigkeitsprüfung
und was also nicht geht ist dass ich
dann außerhalb dieses
gefährdungsgebieten eingreife also in
unserem fall wenn in diesen sogenannten
volksrepublik hier dann möglicherweise
humanitäre ausnahmesituation für die
russische bevölkerung gegeben wären ja
ich spreche im konjunktiv dann
legitimiert aber die unterstützung
dieser personen und der schutz dieser
personen nicht einen angriff auf die
etwas völlig außerhalb dieses gebiets
liegt und damit letztlich auch nichts
nichts zu tun hat also das würde durch
eine humanitäre intervention niemals
gerechtfertigt so jedenfalls meine
ansicht das wäre immer nur dann eine
rechtfertigung für einen punktuellen
einsatz und unmittelbar bedrohte
personen zu schützen dann haben wir
glaube ich die materielle seite des
strafrechts jetzt ganz gut
herausgearbeitet also einmal ist auf
jeden fall das verbrechen der aggression
erfüllen und möglicherweise das käme
dann auf die genauen gegebenheiten vor
ort an auch schon kriegsverbrechen oder
zumindest besteht die gefahr dass das
auch im weiteren kriegsverlauf
verwirklicht werden könnte die andere
frage ist natürlich kann russland jetzt
vor dem internationalen strafgerichtshof
dafür zur verantwortung gezogen werden
wie sieht es da aus ja die durchsetzung
von völker strafe ist ja sicherlich noch
so das große problem auch im völkerrecht
den internationalen strafgerichtshof
haben wir ja seit 2002 und ist aber nur
dann tatsächlich irgendwie in der lage
einzugreifen wenn das verbrechen auf dem
gebiet auf dem staatsgebiet eines
mitgliedstaats stattgefunden hat also
dieses gericht basiert auf dem prinzip
der zustimmung also hat mitgliedstaaten
und nur diese mitgliedstaaten
akzeptieren die rechtsprechungs
kompetenz dieses gerichtshofs und dieser
kann dann also nur in situationen die
sich auf dem territorium eines
mitgliedstaats abspielen dann auch tätig
werden jetzt jedenfalls im grundsatz
das ist jetzt dummerweise hier da nicht
der fall die ukraine ist kein
mitgliedsstaat am internationalen
strafgerichtshofs war sicherlich
politisch nicht klug aus sicht der
ukraine nicht schon vor jahren
beigetreten zu sein aber nun ist es mal
so es gibt dann tatsächlich noch die
möglichkeit auf zweierlei arten adhoc
den internationalen strafgerichtshof
anzurufen nämlich einmal könnte die
ukraine tatsächlich jetzt für eine
gewisse situation für einen gewissen
zeitpunkt der internationale
strafgerichtshof gleichwohl bitten auch
wenn es nicht mitglied ist die
rechtsverfolgung hier zu übernehmen das
hat die ukraine auch für die situation
der krim mal getan das wäre die eine art
übertragungsmöglichkeit die andere wäre
eine möglichkeit dass der sicherheitsrat
der vereinten nationen den
internationalen strafgerichtshof quasi
ersucht die strafverfolgung zu
übernehmen dieser zweite fall ist
natürlich politisch würde ich mal sagen
ausgeschlossen denn im sicherheitsrat
der vereinten nationen sitzt auch
russland und ist dort vetomacht das
heißt die könnten eine entsprechende
resolution mit der die situation an den
internationalen strafgerichtshof
übertragen wird natürlich verhindern das
ist klar genau also diese letzte
variante scheidet schon aus praktischen
gründen aus die erste variante die sie
genannt haben da gibt es ja in der tat
ein historisches beispiel dieses
beispiel der grimme ereignisse da war es
ja so dass am 8 september
2015 die ukraine eben ein brief beim
internationalen strafgerichtshof in den
haag hinterlegt hat und gesagt hat es
sollen jetzt mal die ereignisse seit dem
20 februar untersucht werden die dort
auf ihrem territorium geschehen sind
würde es denn jetzt für diese aktuellen
geschehen ist da noch einen zweiten
brief brauchen oder könnte der
internationale strafgerichtshof auch
sagen na ja das hängt so sehr zusammen
dieser grimm konflikt und die aktuellen
geschehnisse wir nutzen quasi diesen
damaligen brief auch an als legitimation
dafür dass wir uns jetzt damit
beschäftigen also an sich ist das nicht
so nicht so gedacht denn diese sonder
möglichkeit hier der situations
übertragung durch ein nicht
mitgliedsstaat
ist immer gedacht dass da wirklich
spezifische situationen übertragen
werden und auch die spezifischen
zeiträumen und so war das wenn ich das
richtig sehe auch damals dass eben diese
situation in bezug auf die krim hier
übertragen worden ist und das geht nicht
über das jahr 2015 hinaus also das ist
natürlich dann blöd und sicherlich
ungünstig für den internationalen
strafgerichtshof aber das ist so es
bräuchte einen neuen übertragungs akt
und wenn es den aber gäbe also wenn zb
der ukrainische präsident selensky sagen
würde erreichte einen neuen brief ein
dann könnte der internationale
strafgerichtshof
sich zum beispiel bei möglichen
kriegsverbrechen dann der sache annehmen
ja sie haben das auch schon jetzt sehr
richtig eingeschränkt das ging dann
tatsächlich erstmal nur für
kriegsverbrechen oder für verbrechen
gegen die menschlichkeit den verbrechen
der aggression gelten dann wieder
sonderregeln aber bei für diese beiden
tatbestände wäre das wäre das denkbar ja
diese diese sonderregeln habe ich
gesehen die sind ja in artikel 15 des
römischen statuts aufgelistet und ich
finde insbesondere den artikel 15 05
etwas kurios muss ich sagen weil da ja
quasi gesagt wird dass ein staat ich
drücke jetzt mal etwas vereinfacht aus
zustimmen muss wenn das verhandelt
werden soll von dem die die aggression
ausgegangen ist wenn sie um potenzielle
täter geht die staatsangehörige dieses
staates sind können sie mir erklären wie
das zustande kam und vielleicht auch ein
bisschen provokativ gefragt was ist dann
überhaupt diese normen noch wert weil es
wird doch wahrscheinlich nie ein staat
dann zustimmen dass gegen ihn ermittelt
wird ja so was das soll weiß ich nicht
und dass diese normen nicht mehr
exportierbar ist so stimmt so meine
kurze antwort also es ist tatsächlich
frappierend ja aber das war eben teil
dieses kompromisses in kampala dass man
halt den interessen aller staaten da
waren nicht nur die mitgliedsstaaten des
internationalen strafgerichtshofs
versammelt sondern da waren alle staaten
der welt versammelt und konnten damit
reden und die haben eben dafür gesorgt
dass diese norm so wachsweich ist bzw
vom materiellen gehalt ja noch gar nicht
mal so schlecht aber folgen 500
durchsetzbarkeit her eben an so hohe
hürden geknüpft ist dass es im grunde
unmöglich ist diese norm gegen den
willen des speziellen betreffenden
staates durchzusetzen es ginge
möglicherweise wenn alle mitglieder des
sicherheitsrates an einem strang zögen
dann ginge es auch gegen den willen
eines eines staates diese aggression
dann festzustellen aber das geht dann
eben nur über diesen umweg des
sicherheitsrats und darüber mir vorhin
schon gesprochen da russland ein
vetorecht hat ist also ausgeschlossen
dass von der seite irgendwas irgendwas
kommt die staaten hatten eben angst ja
in kampala bei diesen diskussionen und
das war ja auch grund warum das über
jahrzehnte letztlich sich nicht
weiterentwickelt hat dieses verbrechen
der aggression
die haben angst dass das ja vielleicht
auch vorschnell der vorwurf der
aggression erhoben wird das politische
handeln unmöglich gemacht wird ich habe
dafür kein verständnis da spreche ich
jetzt aber natürlich nicht als
jemand der sich mit internationalen
politik beschäftigt sondern als jurist
und als mensch der sagt also es ist halt
der die aggression kein mittel der
politik das darf es auch nicht sein
sondern ist es eben eine strafbare
handlung und da muss man auch dann klar
farbe bekennen und soll nicht so meyer
aber das ist eben auf der
internationalen bühne ganz ganz anders
gesehen worden das fatale dabei ist wie
ich finde dass eben gerade in diesem
punkt das was man im nürnberger
hauptkriegsverbrecherprozess ja so stark
gemacht hat zwar gerade damals dieses
verbrechen gegen den frieden genau das
war es ja was nazi deutschland
vorgeworfen worden ist und dass wir
genau das war auch der die hauptaussage
dieses nürnberger prozesses gerade von
seiten auch der der us-amerikaner dass
sie eine normal ihren wollen die eben
den aggressions krieg ein für allemal
kriminalisiert das war das erklärte ziel
und da sind wir heute also
offensichtlich vor einem scherbenhaufen
das hat nicht nur nicht geklappt sondern
wie wir jetzt sehen wird darüber hinter
gegangen als wir das eben nicht einmal
das papier wert auf dem diese norm
geschrieben steht dann bleibt also
festzuhalten dass sich russland rein
praktisch eher sorgen machen muss wenn
es daneben um kriegsverbrechen oder
verbrechen gegen die menschlichkeit geht
einfach weil dieser dieser tatbestand
der aggression so wachsweich formuliert
ist jetzt ist aber natürlich der
internationale strafgerichtshof
sozusagen nur die die eine ebene es gibt
ja auch noch eine andere ebene das ist
die nationale ebene auch hier in
deutschland und er ist es ja so dass wir
im
völkerstrafgesetzbuch und den
entsprechenden strafprozessualen begleit
vorschriften auch die möglichkeit haben
das eben jemand belangt wird dem
kriegsverbrechen vorgeworfen werden
wie sieht die lage aus also könnte es
sein dass der aktuelle krieg in der
ukraine irgendwann auch deutsche
gerichte beschäftigt ja das ist im
grunde schon schon denkbar hier gibt es
aber wieder genau zu differenzieren also
auch das aggressions verbrechen was wir
im völkerstrafgesetzbuch auch jetzt
wieder finden
muss eben abgegrenzt werden zu
verbrechen gegen die menschlichkeit und
kriegsverbrechen bei diesen
letztgenannten wenn ich damit wieder
anfangen darf oder kriegsverbrechen oder
verbrechen die menschlichkeit gilt
nachfrage auf 1 satz 1 kstg des
völkerstrafgesetzbuchs das sogenannte
universitäts prinzip das heißt hier
könnten deutsche
strafverfolgungsbehörden oder müssen
sogar deutsche strafverfolgungsbehörden
tätig werden völlig unabhängig davon von
wem und wo das internationale verbrechen
begangen worden ist also da haben wir
eine sehr weitgehende befugnisse im
grunde überstreckt die sich auf die
ganze welt und das wird dann prozessual
nur so ein stück weit eingefangen dass
man ihm sagt ja wenn es ausgeschlossen
ist dass man die entsprechende täter
person jemals zu fassen bekommt dann
kann man das zurückstellen und so weiter
aber an sich ist das ein sehr sehr
starkes universitäts prinzip was hier
eben den generalbundesanwalt ermächtigt
verfahren wegen kriegsverbrechen und
verbrechen die menschlichkeit
durchzuführen und wir sehen das ja auch
aktuell das in vielen situationen jetzt
bezogen auf syrien oder möglicherweise
auch um afghanistan
der generalbundesanwalt ermittelt und
hier einige oberlandesgerichte in
deutschland mit den stationen ganz gut
beschäftigt sind mit derartigen
verfahren also würde sagen deutschland
hat da durchaus eine gewisse
vorreiterrolle jetzt zu in europa aber
auch unbedingt weltweit
also dass zudem kriegsverbrechen oder
verbrechen die menschlichkeit beim
verbrechen der aggression und vielleicht
darf ich da an der stelle auch noch mal
dran erinnern dass auch aufgrund unserer
erfahrungen im sogenannten dritten reich
und mit dem furchtbaren aggressions ein
vernichtungskrieg der dann von
deutschland ausging in artikel 26 des
grundgesetzes ja in diesen fundamentalen
dokument unserer gemeinschaft festgelegt
ist dass der aggressions krieg verboten
ist und bestraft werden muss und wir
hatten das also auch schon vor dem
völkerstrafgesetzbuch in § 80 des
strafgesetzbuchs eine norm die eben
tatsächlich den aggressionstrieb
finalisiert hat kam nie zur anwendung
aber sie war da als symbol und als
anspruch dass die das deutsche dass die
deutsche nation dass das nicht das nicht
will und aggressions krieger unter
strafe stellt strafe lief erfolgt so und
jetzt haben wir es in
völkerstrafgesetzbuch geschrieben und
zwar so wie es im römischen statut in
dieser kompromiss heftigkeit sich
wiederfindet das heißt wir haben hier
also liegt grundsätzlich die gleiche
problematik mit der manifesten
verletzung der verein der charta der
vereinten nationen zum einen auf
materielle seite und wir haben auch
prozessual
eine einen weiteren kompromiss den wir
völkerstrafgesetzbuch finden nämlich in
§ 1 satz 2 der das universitäts prinzip
einschränkt und also sagt
aggression wird nur verfolgt wenn die
tat entweder gegen deutschland gerichtet
ist oder wenn der täter deutscher ist ja
und da hier beides noch nicht aber ist
es jedenfalls nicht der fall jetzt in
bezug auf russland und die ukraine kann
also der generalbundesanwalt hier
tatsächlich in bezug auf die aggression
nichts tun
gleichwohl würde ich ihn empfehlen schon
mal eine akte anzulegen mit einem
ermittlungsverfahren in bezug auf
kriegsverbrechen und verbrechen die
menschlichkeit denn da werden sicherlich
strafanzeigen kommen könnte das dann
bedeuten wenn wladimir putin wieder
einmal deutschen boden betreten sollte
das ist ja zurzeit auch aufgrund der
aktuellen sanktionen mehr als fraglich
aber nehmen wir an das wäre der fall und
es gebe solche kriegsverbrechen dass er
dann am flughafen verhaftet werden
könnte müsste dann sogar verhaftet
werden wenn sie ein entsprechendes
ermittlungsverfahren gibt und wenn der
verdacht stark genug ist ja ja dann
haben wir das auch ein bisschen
aufgeklärt auch star beim
völkerstrafgesetzbuch ist also eine ja
eine ähnliche parallele wie bei dem
römischen statut ich würde gerne zum
verständnis noch auf zwei sonder
situationen eingehen die eine
sondersituation ist es kann ja auch
verbrechen geben die nicht direkt von
russland sondern von separatisten im
donbass begangen werden was ändert das
für die rechtliche bewertung das ändert
insofern etwas als wir es dann
jedenfalls bevor russland jetzt
intervenierte wäre es möglicherweise mit
einem nicht internationalen bewaffneten
konflikt zu tun hatten und das
völkerstrafrecht oder das humanitäre
völkerrecht um genau zu sein
differenziert hier zwischen dem
internationalen bewaffneten konflikt und
dem nicht internationalen bewaffneten
konflikt das hat auch historische gründe
und ist die eigentlich nach einer
modernen lesart des humanitären
völkerrechts auch nicht mehr angemessen
aber das römische statut unterscheidet
noch so und wenn also jetzt ohne
russische intervention
freiheitskämpfer gegen ukrainische armee
kämpfen dann ist das ein
innerstaatlicher konflikt und da gelten
dann ein bisschen andere regeln da geht
dann nicht das ganze volle programm des
humanitären völkerrechts zu sein ein
bisschen ein abgespecktes aber man kann
trotzdem auch in dem kontext
und jetzt in pará these die allermeisten
der konflikte der letzten jahre also
afghanistan auch syrien jedenfalls in
teilen waren nicht internationalen
konflikt ihren auch da hat das
humanitäre völkerrecht natürlich etwas
etwas zu sagen und regelungs und
regelungs charakter aber das wäre dann
hier eben in dieser situation
freiheitskämpfer separatisten
truppen gegen eben die staatliche wie
die ukraine das wäre nicht staatlicher
bewaffnete konnten eine entschuldigung
ein innerstaatlicher bewaffnete konflikt
und deswegen müsste man da ein bisschen
differenzieren was die was die genau
straftatbestände anbelangt wie ist es
bei den straftatbeständen eigentlich wer
kann sich quasi so eines
kriegsverbrechens schuldig machen kann
das jetzt nur herrn putin treffen oder
kann das nur befehlshaber in dem krieg
treffen kann das auch den einzelnen
soldaten treffen wir sind da die
voraussetzungen
also in der tat ist es eine ganz
interessante frage und jetzt anders als
das aggressions verbrechen was ja
einführungs verbrechen ist also da
werden dann nur diejenigen belangt oder
können nur belangt werden die auf einem
top-level der staatlichen befehlskette
stehen also präsidenten
verteidigungsminister möglicherweise
umgekehrt ist es eben bei den
kriegsverbrechen das sind die an erst
einmal verantwortlich die tatsächlich
das gewehr in der hand haben und dann
die in zweiter ebene die eben diese
leute befehlen in den sinn als als
offiziere etc es geht dabei ja nicht
irre viel leiter eben nach oben die
zurechnung wird natürlich dann immer
etwas diffiziler wenn
je weiter die person weg ist von dem was
an der front ist geschieht desto mehr
kann sich die person darauf besinnen und
darauf berufen zu sagen ich wusste davon
nichts dass die hier weiß ich nicht die
die die reihenweise vergewaltigen
beispielsweise das war mir nicht bewusst
dann ist es schwierig mit der strafe die
hinzurechnung ja weil wir ja immer nach
dem schuldprinzip den vorsatz des täters
brauchen also auch der hintermann der
befehlshaber der möglicherweise in
moskau setzt der muss eben wissen was
vor ort passiert und da wird zeit mit
der zurechnung dann etwas dann etwas
schwierig aber im prinzip ist jede ebene
vom einfachen soldaten der mit dem
gewehr in der hand losmarschiert bis
eben zu dem der in moskau am
schreibtisch sitzt und die befehle gibt
ist jeder auch wegen kriegsverbrechen
strafbar das ist vielleicht etwas was
sich durchaus der eine oder andere der
gerade an diesem krieg beteiligt ist
auch noch mal bewusst machen sollte ich
würde zum ende unseres gesprächs jetzt
noch ein bisschen generell auf das
völkerstrafrecht gucken jedes
aufgefallen dass anders als zum beispiel
beim konflikt in syrien jetzt insgesamt
in der öffentlichen debatte sehr wenig
über das völkerstrafrecht gesprochen
wurde haben sie das auch so empfunden
und falls ja haben sie eine erklärung
dafür woran könnte das liegen
je kleiner das ist mir auch aufgefallen
und ich finde das auch ein bisschen ein
bisschen traurig ich erkläre mir dass
dadurch dass wir hier von vornherein
sozusagen das mit zwei staaten zu tun
haben in russland und die ukraine die in
beide keine mitgliedstaaten des
internationalen strafgerichtshof sind so
dass man da vielleicht nicht so nicht so
daran gedacht hat aber
zugleich hat man die letzten sommer mal
20 jahre schon festgestellt dass das
thema völkerstrafrecht auch bei
diplomatischen verhandlungen bei
friedensverhandlungen etc eigentlich
immer mit am tisch saß und das war jetzt
hier tatsächlich nicht so ich finde das
sehr bedauerlich denn eigentlich hat
sich das völkerstrafrecht schon jetzt
eben spätestens mit der entwicklung des
oder etablierung des internationalen
strafgerichtshofs als etwas etabliert
was eben im rahmen des völkerrechts im
rahmen der internationalen beziehungen
auch ernst genommen werden muss weil
vielleicht auch erst jahre oder
jahrzehnte später aber weil immer doch
eine strafe liche verantwortung heute
möglich ist ja also das habe ich jetzt
nicht so ganz
dann kann ich nicht so ganz erklären und
verstehen warum das hier nicht mit mit
mit behauptet worden ist und auch
natürlich die die die behauptung hier
wenn das so und so ist dann wäre das ein
aggressions verbrechen auch das hat ja
politisch gewicht würde ich jedenfalls
meinen so dass man das auch mal in eine
diskussion hätte vortragen können aber
das ist nicht geschehen dann könnte es
ja durchaus sein dass das jetzt noch
stärker in den fokus rückt und wir
versuchen natürlich auch mit unserem
heutigen gespräch zumindest einen
kleinen beitrag dazu zu leisten dass man
über über diese frage nachdenkt zuletzt
würde mich noch etwas interessieren was
jetzt nicht so sehr ihre rolle als
strafrechtler betrifft sondern eher ihre
rolle als professor und zwar würde mich
interessieren ob sie in den vergangenen
jahren in irgendeiner weise mit
studenten aus russland oder aus der
ukraine kontakt hatten die sich mit dem
völkerstrafrecht beschäftigt haben ja in
der tat ist das hatte ich und deswegen
finde ich diesen grundkonflikt auch
nochmal so besonders so besonders
schlimm und trifft mich tatsächlich auch
persönlich wir veranstalten ja in
nürnberg den nürnberg moot court also
jedes jahr findet ihr ein treffen statt
von ja so um die 2 300 studierenden aus
der ganzen welt die eben in einem
juristischen wettkampf gegeneinander
antreten und das sind immer fälle die
eben bezug haben zu der dem
völkerstrafrecht spielen meistens mit
bezug auch noch zu den nürnberger
prozessen also ein bisschen historischer
bezug ist auch dabei und in der tat war
also in den letzten jahren waren immer
sogar mehrere teams aus der ukraine also
von
universitäten aus kiew und aus odessa
dabei und in den letzten jahren
tatsächlich auch von von einer moskauer
universität war da eine
studierendengruppe dabei und gerade die
aus der ukraine die haben mir immer
besonders gut gefallen weil sie in einem
wahnsinnigen engagement vorgegangen sind
und unglaublich viel wussten die haben
es tatsächlich immer ins finale
geschafft oder haben irgendeinen preis
gewonnen also preis als für den besten
schriftsatz oder für den besten redner
rednerin oder sowas ist es wirklich
unglaublich mit welchem mit welchem
engagement die dazu zugange gegangen
sind und sie haben sich so wohl gefühlt
in diesem geist und in diesem
kreis der der gleichgesinnten aus der
aus der ganzen welt und das schmerzt
nicht wirklich mit anzusehen wie diese
hoffnungsvollen leuten ja so enttäuscht
wir hatten sie schon die möglichkeit
kontakt mit den studenten oder mit
angehörigen der universitäten in der
ukraine kontakt aufzunehmen und das hat
sich jetzt persönlich nicht wie das
jetzt mit der aktuellen moot court runde
ist kann ich ihnen jetzt auch gar nicht
sagen ob die teams aus der ukraine da
jetzt noch dabei sind oder die iss
befinden uns gerade in der schriftsatz
phase
das habe ich jetzt persönlich nicht
verfolgt das kann ich nicht sagen ja auf
jeden fall hoffen wir das ja auch
künftig wieder studenten aus der ukraine
an solchen wettbewerben teilnehmen
können ich bedanke mich bei ihnen für
ihre zeit und auch für die erläuterung
zur strafrechtlichen bewertung vielen
dank nach erlangen christoph safferling
professor für strafrecht
strafprozessrecht und internationales
strafrecht und völkerrecht er sah
verlegen ich wünsche ihnen trotz allem
ein schönes wochenende wechselnder ihnen
auch danke
[Musik]
das war unser faz einspruch podcast
spezial zum krieg vor unserer haustür
zum krieg in der ukraine eine
kurzfristige talksendung es wird aber
nicht die letzte zu diesem thema gewesen
sein denn es geht ja schließlich um
unsere ordnung unsere art zu leben und
das wird uns weiter beschäftigen
mitte der kommenden woche begrüßt sie
wieder hell in borowski zu einer
regulären ausgabe unseres podcasts
wir bedanken uns fürs zuhören und freuen
uns natürlich auch wieder auf anregungen
und themenvorschläge unserer hörer unter
einspruch podcast faz.de und auch wenn
diese zeit natürlich schwierige zeiten
sind und ja die stimmung nicht so gut
ist wie sonst wünschen wir ihnen liebe
hörer trotzdem ein schönes wochenende
auch von mir ein gutes wochenende und
bleiben sie anspruch treu
[Musik]